traditionally coupies have been sporty
or elegant or exclusive rarely seen and
road test reviews were such attributes
as spacious or practical the new
Mercedes CLA 180 shooting brake is out
to show us that a marriage between a
coupe a and the station wagon can be a
success
the design is certainly daring but
consummated the flat roof line and
sloping windows give the CLA the look of
a drawn bow ready to fire although the
shooting brake does not seem stretched
the flattened rear has the typical CLA
lamps and a sizable roof spoiler with
integrated antenna the basic engine
options might not quite fit the agile
appearance take the 1.6 litre
turbocharged gasoline unit with 90
kilowatts of power and 200 newton meters
of torque nothing to sneeze at but the
slick looking body may ultimately hint
at more style than substance
this topic the suspension is very nicely
balanced concludes expert mantener dorfa
it's sporty enough considering the
design but also both surprisingly good
ride comfort the steering and the
six-speed manual transmission also play
their part except the gear ratios are
way too long the CLA Shooting Brake
solid handling also holds up in swerve
testing the wagon come Kupe glides
around the pylons with ease and for a
hard stop from 100 km/h the mercedes
takes an average distance of just thirty
five point four meters on the inside
sports seats plus aluminum rimmed air
vents and the classic instrument dials
provide a dynamic field on the down side
rear seat passengers in particular could
do with a little more room the trunk has
a healthy cargo capacity of between 345
and 705 liters but the design won't
allow a wider trunk opening and
visibility through the back is poor
sherman automobile clubs eco test
standards show that the CLA 180 Shooting
Brake consumes 5.8 liters of regular
unleaded gas per 100 kilometers the
manufacturers official figure is five
and a half liters
the thoughts of a million blood if you
still want a sporty design but also a
family-oriented car the CLA Shooting
Brake is a decent option it does lose
points on the interior space in front
and the relatively high starting price
of just under thirty thousand euros
might put off some buyers